auf den sieg stoßen sie an pascal
machten die ihre mitstreiter dass die
guter laune sind liegt nicht nur am
kleinen volksfest in der dordogne
martell ist parlaments kandidaten des
neuen bündnisses aus linken kommunisten
sozialisten und grünen das zum ersten
mal an es hat absprachen getroffen wer
wo im land an den kandidaten aufstellen
wir wollen diese starke union um eine
starke gruppe zu haben gegen die politik
des präsidenten
einigkeit macht stark wir wollen mit
einer mehrheit im parlament die
sogenannten reformen des präsidenten
verhindern
er verpasst dem bild begleiten linken
kratzer florian war die ju verteilt
eigene bewerbung er gehört zum
sozialdemokratischen flügel der
sozialistischen partei und tritt im
wahlkreis in der dordogne gegen die
kandidatin der linken an die seine
eigene partei unterstützt für wähler
wird es kompliziert
guten tag ich bin kandidat bei der
parlamentswahl für die linke schade dass
hier die sozialistische partei verlassen
haben ich habe die sozialisten nicht
verlassen das ist nur vorübergehend für
meine kandidatur
na dann wollen wir mal hoffen dass das
klappt ich werde alles dafür tun
so tobt ein kampf unter den roten und
nicht nur in diesen ländlichen wahlkreis
mit folgen für die gesamte politische
landschaft frankreichs das
mehrheitswahlrecht führt dazu dass immer
nur einer gewinnen kann darum wird der
streit mit den linken dissidenten
erbittert geführt ich denke das ist ein
echter irrtum das ist echter fahrrad
gegenüber den wählerinnen und wähler
man hat verlangt unser programm
aufzugeben und keine linke mehr zu sein
dirigieren und reformieren will um eine
radikale linke zu werden die viel
verspricht und nichts halten kann
anders als die radikale linke will war
die jod zum beispiel das rentenalter
nicht auf 60 jahre senken war das nicht
zu finanzieren sei die mangelnde
unterstützung seiner eigenen partei
villa dadurch wettmachen dass er hier
viel unterwegs ist
ich will mindestens zwei dreimal in jede
gemeinde gehen und meine vorschläge
verteilen es gibt ein gefühl abgehängt
zu sein in ländlichen gegenden um das zu
bekämpfen muss man praktische politik
machen und präsenz zeigen
die deponien südwestfrankreich ist eine
landwirtschaftlich geprägte
strukturschwache region viele ältere
leben hier oft mit niedrigen einkommen
bei der parlamentswahl geht es für viele
um die soziale absicherung
[Musik]
die kaufkraft dass das wichtigste thema
die kaufkraft die hohen benzinpreise und
die preise für nahrungsmittel
das leben ist einfach zu teuer geworden
die hauptsorge ist der krieg in der
ukraine
man hat keine angst vor dem krieg an
sich weil er ja weit weg ist man hat
keine angst dass putin hier
einmarschiert oder so aber man hat angst
um die konjunktur und was noch alles
passieren kann
kontakt madame ich komme wegen der
parlamentswahlen
ich trete an für die neue ökologische
und soziale volksunion
pascal martin wie die soziale
unsicherheit für sich nutzen wahlkampf
in einer siedlung mit sozialwohnungen
die linke liste will einen deutlich
höheren mindestlohn die verstaatlichung
von schlüsseln unternehmen höhere
steuern für reiche doch ein selbstläufer
ist das selbst hier nicht
ich wähle makro und seine leute
ich war mal bei den kommunisten und dann
war ich bei den sozialisten und das
brachte gar nichts
machen hat die wohn steuer abgeschafft
das bringt mir 1200 euro im jahr
wir wollen die energiepreise einfrieren
damit sie mir sparen ach da nimmt der
parteichef doch seinen mund wieder zu
voll wie immer
politik ist hier verboten keine politik
hier
ich mache keine politik hier ich kaufe
fleisch
philipp schwaß erste amtsinhaber im
wahlkreis dazu immer nur macros mehrheit
gehört die zweifel an der
regierungsfähigkeit und der streit und
den linken stimmen ihn zuversichtlich im
parlament bleiben zu können
ich glaube nicht dass diese neue linke
liste lange halten würde man sieht ja
wie sich die sozialistische partei
gerade selbst auflöst es gibt einen teil
der linken der progressiv ist und zu
reformen beitragen will man kann
annehmen dass einige von ihnen
gelegentlich mit uns zusammen abstimmen
werden
einigkeit gibt es hier am grill als
vegetarier wird man in dieser gegner
nichts 50 mal im wahlkampf lädt der
sozialist flora war die jungs zum
barbecue doch er glaubt dass allein der
wille makro das leben schwer zu machen
nicht ausreicht für gemeinsame politik
wir müssen die parlamentswahl abwarten
um zu sehen ob die sozialistische partei
nicht schon bald wieder zurück zu sich
selbst findet ich wette dass diese
einheitsliste für die wahl die eine
falsche union der linken da stellt sich
ab dem tag des zweiten wahlgangs
auflösen wird
es gibt mehr als das linke und das
regierungslager doch der kampf zwischen
ihnen wird maßgeblich entscheiden ob
präsident marco im parlament seine
reformen durchsetzen kann oder
frankreich fünf jahre politische lähmung
erlebt
[Musik]